This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。绝对真人。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《吃一堑长一智》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的心理治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方根本不敢进行的真诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲？它向世界释放出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做。收听《吃一堑长一智》
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能以及在我们这个奇奇怪怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO%，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟是同一个声名狼藉的世纪骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他一定会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
收听《闺蜜们：相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe），在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。在《回顾往昔》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，那对对我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the Psychology of Your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Before we get into it, I want to let you guys know that this episode and the psychology of your 20s is now on Netflix.
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。收听《回顾往昔》，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克（Jemma Spike），欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时经历的重大变化、重要时刻和人生转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么。在进入正题之前，我想告诉大家，本期节目以及《20多岁的心理学》现在已经登陆 Netflix 了。
That is a wild thing to say, but it is true. If you want to watch the video version of this podcast and you are in the US or Canada, you can go to Netflix right now, look up the psychology of your 20s, and you will see my face and you will see our podcasts. It goes without saying it is such an honor and I'm truly so grateful to you all that you have given me this opportunity. The entire feel, the vibe is incredible. I think it's so personal. It brings a whole new element to it. And if you want to feel like you were sitting in your living room, in my living room, with me, having a chat, now is your opportunity.
说出这句话感觉太疯狂了，但这是真的。如果你想观看这个播客的视频版，并且你身处美国或加拿大，你现在就可以打开 Netflix，搜索《20多岁的心理学》，你就会看到我的脸，也会看到我们的播客。这是不言而喻的巨大荣誉，我真的非常感谢大家给了我这个机会。整个氛围、这种感觉简直不可思议。我觉得它非常个人化。它为节目带来了一种全新元素。如果你想感受一下自己仿佛正坐在你的客厅、我的客厅里，和我一起聊天，现在就是你的机会。
Go to Netflix, look up the psychology of your 20s. I'd love to see you over there. But without further ado, let's get into the episode. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It's so great to have you here.
去 Netflix 搜索《20多岁的心理学》。我很期待在那里见到你们。但话不多说，让我们进入本期节目。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴有你们在这里。
back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. So this is something that I've been asked about so many times over the years that, honestly, countless times I've lost count. I've asked it myself when I was dating. The question that me and my friends would always talk about was like, how in the world are you meant to find dating enjoyable when dating apps seem to be the only way to date? no one's meeting in person anymore. The meet cute is dead.
回归又一期节目，我们一起来剖析20多岁的心理。所以，这是这些年来我被问过无数次的问题，说实话，次数多到我都数不清了。我自己当年约会时也问过这个问题。我和朋友们经常讨论的问题是，当约会软件似乎成了唯一的约会途径时，你到底该怎么在约会中找到乐趣？根本没有人在线下见面了。完美的偶遇（meet cute）已经消亡了。
People meeting through friends is like a faraway fantasy. How do you operate in that system when you're still a hopeless romantic, but the dating apps just feel so pointless when you want your love story, but it's like I've been at this for a while. When is it going to be me? How do we survive the dating apps? When again, it feels like the only option left, despite knowing deep down, it's basically turned dating in.
通过朋友认识简直就像是一个遥不可及的幻想。当你内心依然是个无可救药的浪漫主义者，但约会软件却让人觉得毫无意义时，你该如何在那个系统中运作？当你渴望属于自己的爱情故事，却发现“我已经单身折腾这么久了，什么时候才轮到我”时。我们该如何在约会软件中存活下来？当再次面对这种情况时，它感觉就像是仅剩的唯一选择，尽管你内心深处知道，它基本上已经把约会变成了
to a game. This is something, as I said, a lot of my friends are going through right now. Even our researcher Libby is dealing with this, like, pessimism. Even the phrase dealing with, like, that's very indicative of the type of conversations we've been having. But she was in London the other day. We were having dinner. And she raised this really crucial point. The dating apps don't want you to win, regardless of like the catchy taglines, designed to be deleted, whatever it is like they're a business they want you swiping for as long as possible the same way social media apps want you scrolling for as long as possible because of this because of this system they're set into a business system i think i've noticed a lot more people experiencing what i call dating burnout
一场游戏。正如我所说，我身边的很多朋友现在都在经历这种情况。甚至连我们的研究员莉比（Libby）也在应付这种悲观情绪。甚至连“应付”这个词，都很能说明我们最近一直在进行的这种对话。但她前几天在伦敦。我们一起吃晚饭。她提出了一个非常关键的观点。约会软件并不希望你成功，不管那些诸如“为卸载而设计”之类的醒目宣传语怎么说，不管是什么口号，它们都是生意，它们希望你尽可能长时间地不停右滑，就像社交媒体应用希望你尽可能长时间地不停刷信息流一样。正因为这一点，因为这个被纳入商业体系的机制，我想我注意到越来越多的人正在经历我所说的“约会倦怠”。
because of how the apps are structured like it's so exhausting that people are kind of giving up hope I actually saw a really interesting article titled What I Wish I knew before Dating at 20 by this guy called Aden. And in the article, he talks about how what the apps base our choices off of, who they show us, who they think will like, is actually completely shallow. We put so much trust in these algorithms. But, you know, to be in a long-term relationship, if that's what you're after, you have to be really open-minded.
因为这些软件的结构——实在是太累人了，以至于人们开始有点放弃希望了。我实际上看到了一篇非常有趣的文章，标题是《我在20岁约会前希望知道的事》，作者是一个叫阿登（Aden）的小伙子。在文章中，他谈到了软件挑选我们的选项、向我们展示谁、以及他们认为我们会喜欢谁的依据，其实全都是极度肤浅的。我们将太多的信任寄托在这些算法上。但是，你知道的，要想拥有一段长期的关系——如果那是你所追求的话，你必须思想非常开放。
You have to be curious. You have to be able to navigate conflict. You have to have to have similar values. You have to be kind. You have to be interested in aligning your life paths. But, you know, the things that get assessed on Hinge, on Tinder, on Bumble are just completely opposite to any of that. They ask you, you know, what's your height? What's your star sign?
你必须充满好奇心。你必须具备处理冲突的能力。你们必须拥有相似的价值观。你必须善良。你必须对齐头并进的人生轨迹感兴趣。但是，你知道的，在 Hinge、Tinder、Bumble 上被评估的东西，和所有这些完全是背道而驰的。它们会问你，你知道的，你的身高是多少？你的星座是什么？
Give me as many hot and interesting pictures or funny pictures of you as you can find. Then they overwhelm me with choice so that anyone who actually is good gets drowned out. if they don't immediately capture attention through very shallow means. They also get overwhelmed back. And so they never message you back that everybody's getting ghosted. Like, you know, all those educational videos is going to be so different to what I was just talking about. But you know those educational videos where like the sperm is like getting to the egg and it's
尽可能多地提供最性感、最有趣的照片，或者你能找到的自己最滑稽的照片。然后，它们会用海量的选择淹没你，以至于任何真正优秀的人都会被大浪淘沙般淹没。如果他们无法通过非常肤浅的手段立刻抓住你的注意力。他们自己也会被海量的选择淹没。于是他们就再也不给你发信息了，每个人都在被“断联失联”（ghosting）。就像，你知道的，所有那些教育视频——这跟我刚才说的可能完全不同，但你知道那种教育视频吗，比如精子正游向卵子，然后
like this race of like, and it's meant to show you like when you're in high school how slim your chances were and how competitive it was and how lucky and rare it is to be alive. that is genuinely what I think it feels like being on the dating apps these days. It feels like your chances of meeting somebody is like you're on a race with these thousands of other potentials and you want to make the match. I know that sounds very doom and gloom and we're being very pessimistic about dating apps, but despite all that, like I do still think they work. I met my partner on hinge.
就像是一场赛跑，而这本该向你展示，当你还在高中时，你的机率是多么微乎其微，竞争是多么激烈，你能活下来是多么幸运和罕见。这真的就是我觉得现在使用约会软件的感觉。感觉你遇到某人的机率，就像你在和成千上万的其他潜在对象进行一场赛跑，而你只想成功配对。我知道这听起来非常厄运连连、阴暗压抑，而且我们对约会软件持相当悲观的态度，但尽管如此，我依然觉得它们管用。我在 Hinge 上遇到了我的伴侣。
A lot of my friends have met their partners on hinge. They work if you have a strategy. and I think that they, my friends have found success for some very specific reasons that people can copy. There is a specific mindset you have to have when you enter the dating app realm that I think is going to ensure you success more than if you just go in there randomly. And that is exactly what I'm going to share with you today. Those very tips for being successful in the dating apps. Without further ado, let's jump into. them let's see how we're going to survive this kind of new dating system that we all operate in
我的很多朋友都在 Hinge 上遇到了他们的伴侣。如果你有策略，它们就会管用。而且我认为，我的朋友们之所以能取得成功，是有一些非常具体的原因，是大家都可以复制的。当你进入约会软件的领域时，你必须具备一种特定的心态，我认为这比你盲目地闯进去更能确保你的成功。而这正是我今天要与你们分享的内容。这些就是在约会软件上获得成功的秘诀。话不多说，让我们直接切入正题。让我们看看我们该如何在这个我们都在其中运作的全新约会系统中存活下来。
stay with us let's not waste any time here let's get right into tip number one if you want to be better at surviving managing the dating apps you need to number one understand the psychology but behind why and how dating apps work and specifically how they make money this will transform your relationship to the platform and by changing your relationship to the platform, this will change the relationships that you have on them. I said it before. I think dating apps aren't designed to be effective. They're designed to be addictive.
留下来，我们在这里不浪费任何时间，直接进入第一条小窍门。如果你想更好地在约会软件中存活、管理它们，你必须做到第一点：理解约会软件运作背后以及它们如何赚钱的心理学，特别是它们是如何盈利的。这将改变你与这些平台的关系，而通过改变你与平台的关系，这也将改变你在这些平台上建立的关系。我之前就说过。我认为约会软件的设计初衷并不是为了高效。它们的设计初衷是为了让人上瘾。
They deliberately give this impression that the perfect relationship can be discovered rather than made and built. And they do this by providing us with all these matches and all this arbitrary information, essentially convincing you that like your job right now is to pick. You've just got to pick and you've got to make sure it's the best one. They're manufactured to sell you this narrative that you're kind of always one swipe away from someone better than the person before. You're always one swipe away from the one. And that keeps you picking up the phone again and again because love is like such a delicious promise all of us want it.
它们刻意制造出这样一种印象：完美的恋情是靠“发现”的，而不是靠创造和建立的。它们通过向我们提供所有这些匹配对象和所有这些随意的信件信息来做到这一点，本质上是说服你：你目前的工作就是挑选。你只需要挑选，并且你得确保选到的是最好的那个。它们被精心制造出来，向你兜售这样一种叙事：你离一个比前一个人更好的人，永远只差轻轻一滑。你离“真命天子（女）”永远只差轻轻一滑。这让你一次又一次地拿起手机，因为爱情是一个如此诱人的承诺，我们所有人都在渴望它。
And it means that we carry on the search despite sometimes matching with people that are like really nice. And people that we really click with. But the possibility of more that is offered by this like endless kind of vacuum of people means that we don't always prioritize those people. Means that actually the level of choice ends up being suffocating. Actually there is this really interesting 2012 article from the researcher Eli Finkel. and also their colleagues, and they look at how online dating, because of how many choices they offer, actually reduces three-dimensional people, four-dimensional, five-dimensional people. It reduces our robust personhood into a two-dimensional display of information or a two-dimensional
这意味着我们继续着搜索，尽管有时我们匹配到的人真的很不错。而且是我们真的很有共鸣的人。但这种由无休止的人类真空状态所提供的“更多可能性”，意味着我们并不总是把这些人放在首位。这意味着事实上，选择的数量最终会达到令人窒息的程度。事实上，研究人员伊利·芬克尔（Eli Finkel）及其同事在2012年发表过一篇非常有趣的文章。他们探讨了在线约会由于提供了过多的选择，实际上是如何将三维的人、四维、五维的人进行降维的。它将我们作为一个完整的人的丰富性，简化成了二维的信息展示或一个二维的
character. This actually reduces how good we are at choosing who we'd click with. Dating apps promote this assessment-oriented mindset where we kind of fall into the role of assessor and maybe unintentionally objectify potential partners. And if we start viewing someone as an object rather than as a real living, breathing, feeling human, that is the danger. It actually reduces the likelihood that we want to commit to even getting to know that person because to us, we're seeing so many people constantly, they just lose all dimension. In studies, researchers have found that people often reject those on dating apps that in person they would psychologically be most compatible with.
角色。这实际上降低了我们挑选出与自己合拍的人的能力。约会软件助长了一种以评估为导向的心态，让我们不知不觉地落入了评估者的角色，并且可能在无意中将潜在伴侣物化了。如果我们开始把一个人看作一个物体，而不是一个真正活着、会呼吸、有感觉的人，这才是危险所在。这实际上降低了我们想要承诺去真正了解那个人的可能性，因为对我们来说，我们不断看到这么多的人，他们失去了所有的立体感。在研究中，研究人员发现，人们经常会拒绝约会软件上那些在现实生活中与他们心理契合度最高的人。
And they do that for really, really small things. Like, they had too many pictures with their friends. I didn't like his shirt. She had two selfies instead of one. And we do this, and we've all done this. We do this because we have so many choices on dating apps. we have to come up with these like silly, arbitrary, shallow little rules just so that we can process such a vast amount of information. We actually end up eliminating lots of really good matches because those rules, they don't make any sense.
而他们拒绝的原因极其微小。比如：他们和朋友合影太多了。我不喜欢他的衬衫。她发了两张自拍而不是一张。我们都会这样做，我们所有人都这么做。我们这么做是因为我们在约会软件上有太多的选择。我们不得不编造出这些愚蠢的、随意的、肤浅的小规则，好让我们能够处理如此庞大的信息量。我们最终淘汰了许多非常好的匹配对象，因为这些规则根本毫无意义。
They're just us trying to figure out the system. All of this is gamifying the mechanics of dating, which makes it both unproductive to begin with because we don't even really make good choices, but also addictive because it is unproductive. A huge reason dating apps are addictive is because they provide intermittent, unpredictable reward, which is essentially the principle behind operant conditioning, which is the principle behind gambling. Your brain learns pretty fast when rewards aren't guaranteed versus when they are, which is why when it's unsure, it stays much longer. Its attention is much more hooked because of anticipation.
那不过是我们试图搞懂这个系统的表现。所有这一切都在将约会的机制“游戏化”（gamifying），这使得它一开始就毫无成效——因为我们甚至无法做出真正好的选择，但同时又让人上瘾——正是因为它的毫无成效。约会软件之所以让人上瘾的一个巨大原因，在于它们提供间歇性的、不可预测的奖励，这本质上就是操作性条件反射（operant conditioning）背后的原理，也就是赌博背后的原理。当奖励无法得到保证与能够得到保证相比时，你的大脑会学得相当快，这就是为什么当它不确定时，它会停留更久。由于期待，它的注意力被勾得更紧。
We know that most swipes lead to nothing, but sometimes you get a match and occasionally you get a really good match with somebody you really, really like. That keeps you hooked. In the literature on operant conditioning, unpredictable rewards are exactly the kind that keep behavior going the longest, even longer than predictability, even longer than knowing when you're going to receive a reward for a certain behavior.
我们知道大多数右滑都毫无结果，但有时你会匹配成功，偶尔你还会和某个你真正、真正喜欢的人来一次超棒的匹配。这让你欲罢不能。在关于操作性条件反射的文献中，不可预测的奖励正是那种能将行为维持最长时间的奖励，甚至比可预测性维持得更久，甚至比你知道在某种特定行为后何时能获得奖励维持得更久。
So this is what's happening. You keep coming back time and time again just because there's a chance. There's a chance that you're going to find someone you actually like or who is attractive or who piques your interest. But dating apps as well, there's always this comparison to gambling. I feel like we've talked about it so many times. they also add something that gambling doesn't, which is a layer of social evaluation. I think this is really critical.
所以这就是正在发生的事情。你一次又一次地回来，仅仅因为存在这种可能性。存在一种可能性：你会找到一个你真正喜欢的人，或者有吸引力的人，或者能激起你兴趣的人。但约会软件也是如此，它总是让人联想到赌博。我觉得我们已经讨论过无数次了。它们还增加了一样赌博所没有的东西——一层社会评价。我认为这本当に（真的）至关重要。
A match is great. It isn't just a reward, though. It's not like money. It's also about the social element. It's the feeling of being wanted. Money is great. Being chosen is better. A 2016 study published in mobile media and communication
匹配成功当然很棒。但这不仅是一个奖励，虽然它不像金钱那样。它还关乎社交元素。那是被渴望的感觉。金钱固然很好。被选择则更好。2016年发表在《移动媒体与通信》（Mobile Media and Communication）上的一项研究
conducted a survey to look at the motives behind why people use Tinder specifically. And what they found was that a lot of the time, men reported using Tinder for sex, for hookups, for seeking relationships. Women, on the other hand, reported using it for friendship, actually, but also for self-validation. Friendship aspect, a little bit confused by, kind of surprised me. Like, I can't say I've ever made a friend from. Tinder, much less somebody I've wanted to know for longer than an afternoon, but the self-validation point, I think, didn't surprise me at all. If the app becomes a place, you know you can go to
进行了一项调查，旨在探讨人们专门使用 Tinder 的动机背后是什么。他们发现，很多时候，男性报告使用 Tinder 是为了性、为了约炮（hookups）、为了寻找恋爱关系。而女性则报告说，她们实际上是为了友谊，但也为了自我验证（self-validation）。友谊这一点，我有点困惑，让我感到挺惊讶的。呃，我不能说我曾在 Tinder 上交到过朋友，更不用说那些我想认识超过一个下午的人了，但关于自我验证这一点，我觉得一点也不意外。如果这个app变成了一个你知道自己可以去的地方——
get validation when you're feeling bad about yourself or in need of reassurance, where it's a place you can go when you know you're going to get a swipe, you know you're going to get a match, you know it's going to make you feel better. That validation is one of the most, oh my God, intoxicating things ever, it can train you through like, through like pure biology to start compulsively checking. Let's be honest, dating apps weren't set up out of the good of someone's heart, right? They are businesses. They are businesses at the end of the day. And that doesn't automatically make them evil.
当你自我感觉糟糕或需要安慰时去那里获取验证，或者当你知道自己去那里一定能右滑成功、一定能匹配成功、一定能让自己感觉好受一点时，这个地方就是你所依赖的。这种验证是最令人陶醉的事情之一，天哪，它可以通过纯粹的生物学机制训练你开始强迫性地查看手机。老实说，约会软件可不是出于某人的善心而创立的，对吧？它们是生意。归根结底，它们就是生意。但这并不自动意味着它们是邪恶的。
Of course not. You know, businesses can create things that are genuinely helpful. But when you understand the incentives underneath the design, the choice overload, the emotional levers being pulled, the intermittent reinforcement, I think it helps us to maybe distance ourselves a little bit and go a little bit slower, maybe match with fewer people, maybe concentrate our time on being intentional about our method rather than just endlessly swiping. Understanding how the apps make money is just essential. This is the part that I haven't even spoken on yet, but most major dating apps run on what they call a freemium model. So a freemian model is basically where most people
当然不是。你知道的，企业完全可以创造出真正有帮助的东西。但是，当你理解了隐藏在设计底下的动机——选择过载、被拉动的那些情感杠杆、间歇性强化，我认为这有助于我们稍微保持一点距离，放慢一点脚步，也许少匹配几个人，也许将我们的精力集中在方法的刻意性上，而不是无休止地右滑。理解这些软件是如何赚钱的至关重要。这是我甚至还没谈到过的一部分，但大多数主流约会软件都采用他们所谓的“免费增值”（freemium）模式。所以，免费增值模式基本上就是大部分人
are going to use the basic free version, but then there are some people who are going to pay to upgrade and they're the ones holding the whole system together. Paying to upgrade means that the app isn't working well enough for you on the basic level. It means that you're not getting enough matches, you're not getting enough attention. And that means that there is an incentive financial for apps like Tinder, Hinge, Bumble, to not give you a good service because otherwise they wouldn't be able to upgrade. And there are all these financial reports from Match.com who owns a lot of those that actually show a lot of their revenue comes from low dollar transactions. People who are choosing to upgrade for $3, $5 because they think it's worth it. When you feel like you're getting nowhere, when you're frustrated, you're going to pay to make it easier for yourself.
都会使用基础的免费版，但同时有一部分人会付费升级，而正是这些人支撑起了整个系统。付费升级意味着该app在基础层面上对你来说不够好用。这意味着你没有获得足够的匹配，你没有得到足够的关注。这意味着像 Tinder、Hinge、Bumble 这样的软件存在一种财务上的动机——不给你提供良好的服务，因为如果服务太好，你就不会付费升级了。Match.com（该公司拥有其中许多软件）的所有这些财务报告实际上都显示，他们的很大一部分收入来自于低额交易。那些选择花3美元、5美元进行升级的人，因为他们觉得这很值得。当你觉得自己毫无进展、感到沮丧时，你会花钱来让自己更轻松一点。
Again, reverse logic. If you know you make money when your users are frustrated because they'll need a premium service, why would you not design the app to be frustrating if your objective is money? And I know that sounds all very like, oh my God, conspiracy theory, but the math, like the data is right there that makes so much money off of this. Why would they design it to be amazing? Why would they design it for everybody to meet their soulmate within one swipe? Their business model would be kaput. I think, though, when you know this, and when you know that the apps are playing a game with our emotions,
再次强调，逆向逻辑。如果你知道当你的用户感到沮丧时你就能赚钱，因为他们会需要高级服务，那么如果你的目标是赚钱，你为什么不把软件设计得让人沮丧呢？我知道这听起来很像是什么阴谋论，但数学原理——数据就摆在那里，它们通过这个赚了那么多的钱。它们为什么要把软件设计得完美无缺呢？为什么要把软件设计得让每个人只需轻轻一滑就能遇到灵魂伴侣呢？那它们的商业模式就彻底破产了。不过我认为，当你明白了这一点，当你意识到这些app正在拿我们的情绪做游戏、
playing a game with our vulnerable moments, you can play them back. And that kind of brings me naturally into tip number two. these apps operate on a sense of lawlessness and just like ambiguity and uncertainty. That is why you have to have rules, very clear rules for yourself for how to approach them. These rules that you determine will obviously depend on who you are and they will change from person to person. But I cannot stress enough, firstly outlining what it is you actually want from the app. before you start swiping. Are you looking for a relationship?
拿我们脆弱的时刻做游戏时，你就可以反过来玩它们。这就很自然地把我带到了第二条小窍门。这些app建立在一种无法无天、模棱两可和不确定的感觉之上。这就是为什么你必须为自己制定规则，关于如何接近它们的非常清晰的规则。你所确定的这些规则显然取决于你是谁，并且会因人而异。但我怎么强调都不为过，首先要在开始右滑之前，明确写下你到底从这个app中寻求什么。你是想找一段恋爱关系？
Are you looking for something casual? The moment that you start to kind of swing away from that goal or lose touch with that goal, I need you to take a break. Especially if you're looking for a long-term relationship and you're ending up in all these small relationships, it just shows that you're being overwhelmed
还是想找段随意的关系？从你开始偏离这个目标或与该目标失去联系的那一刻起，我需要你休息一下。特别是如果你在寻找一段长期的关系，却最终陷入了所有这些短暂的恋爱中，这只能说明你已经不堪重负，
such that you are not in touch with your true desire anymore. Design your interactions with the app to best suit your desired outcome. If you want a relationship, if you want something casual, if you're not sure, how you approach it is going to determine what you get from this situation. When we get a bit fed up and fatigued with swiping or liking or getting nowhere, we definitely develop this scarcity mindset that pushes us into making pretty poor decisions. This has happened to me.
以至于你不再与自己真正的渴望保持联系了。设计你与app的互动，使其最符合你期望的结果。如果你想要一段关系，如果你想要随意的关系，如果你不确定，你接近它的方式将决定你从这种情况下得到什么。当我们对右滑、点赞或毫无进展感到有点厌倦和疲惫时，我们绝对会产生一种稀缺心态（scarcity mindset），这会促使我们做出相当糟糕的决定。这在我身上发生过。
I remember, like, the dating apps were so exhausting back in the day, like, that I just started to lower my standards and accept lesser treatment or accept people in that like I had no future with and that's not and that wasn't conducive to like the kind of relationship goals that I have dating apps are uniquely brilliant at creating what I'd call emotional loose threads this is like half conversations maybe plans ghost chats people who pop back up every three weeks like a freaking haunted Victorian child and those loose threads add to a big cognitive load. Like there is this vague stress following us around everywhere because we've like poured a little bit of energy into all these people and we're kind of, we can't keep track of them.
我记得，过去约会软件让人太筋疲力尽了，以至于我开始降低标准，接受较差的待遇，或者接受那些我根本看不到未来的对象，这不利于我所拥有的那种恋爱目标。约会软件有一种独特的高明之处，那就是制造我所说的“情感乱麻”（emotional loose threads）。这就像是半生不熟的对话、也许压根没落实的计划、像该死的维多利亚时期闹鬼小孩一样每隔三周又突然蹦出来的幽灵聊天对象，而这些乱麻增加了大量的认知负担。就像有一种模糊的压力无时无刻不在跟着我们，因为我们在所有这些人身上倾注了一点点精力，而我们有点……无法掌控它们了。
Where is that energy going? Like we cannot sustain that forever. Each one of those almost maybe little things is taxing. So when you put your rules in place, you protect that energy from, from, I don't know, from the clutter, I think we all need better dating app hygiene. Like, do not leave your matches unattended or unanswered, like dirty dishes or leftover food. If you're not going to touch it in the next 12 to 24 hours, you're not going to want it in two days or two months. Unmatch. Give them their time back. Give yourself your time back.
这些精力都去哪儿了？我们根本无法永远维持这种状态。每一个那种“差不多吧”的小事情都是一种消耗。所以，当你制定规则时，你是在保护这些精力免受……我不知道，免受杂乱的侵扰。我认为我们都需要更好的约会软件卫生习惯。比如：不要让你的匹配对象无人理睬或无人回复，就像脏盘子或剩饭剩菜一样。如果你不打算在接下来的12到24小时内联系他们，你也不会在两天或两个月后想搭理他们。取消匹配。把他们的时间还给他们。把你的时间还给自己。
Like, clean up after yourself. these are the specific rules. I know I've kind of talked about this very abstractly. The specific rules that I think you should instigate, take it or leave it. Rule number one, when you match with somebody, either of you have 24 hours to message, otherwise you unmatch. Simple. This shows like if somebody is interested, if you're interested enough,
就像，自己收拾干净。这些就是具体的规则。我知道我刚才讲得非常抽象。我认为你们应该设立的具体规则，接受与否由你。规则一：当你和某人匹配后，你们双方有24小时的时间发信息，否则就取消匹配。就这么简单。这表明如果有人感兴趣，如果你有足够的兴趣，
you will reach out. You will make contact. If not, no hard feelings. Like this is the, you know, that's, that scene in like the, blind side where it's like if you don't like it in the store you're not going to like it at home. Same with the dating apps. If you don't like them at the first impression, you're not going to change your mind in two days. And if you do change your mind, it's going to be because you're bored.
你会主动联系。你会进行接触。如果没有，也别放在心上。就像那个……你知道的，电影《弱点》（The Blind Side）里那个场景，意思是在商店里如果你不喜欢它，你在家里也不会喜欢它。约会软件也是一样。如果你在第一印象时就不喜欢他们，你在两天内也不会改变主意。如果你真的改变了主意，那也一定是因为你无聊了。
And that's not fair for anybody. 24 hours, unmatch. Another rule, similar to that one. If they've stopped replying, literally hit them up with like a, hey, where did you go? Kind of message in like a kind, funny way. If they don't respond to that message, unmatch. 12 hours, 24 hours, especially if you've been messaging pretty consistently up until that point. Again, we are at stage one of the dating process. There is no room for potential. There is only room for
这对任何人都不公平。24小时，取消匹配。另一条规则，类似于上一条。如果他们停止回复了，直接用一种友好、有趣的方式给他们发一条诸如“嗨，你跑哪儿去了？”之类的信息。如果他们对那条信息没有回应，取消匹配。12小时，24小时，特别是如果在此之前你们一直聊得相当稳定的话。再次强调，我们正处于约会流程的第一阶段。这里没有“潜力”的空间。这里只有
facts. Like, if they can't come through right now, no, no, no. A similar version of this, one of my friends actually has this rule where if they haven't met up within a week, I think it is, a week and a half, or there isn't a concrete plan made to meet within that next week, then she unmatches. It turns out that a lot of the research into successful use of dating apps backs this method up. Studies suggest that modality switching, basically moving from online to offline interactions, is really beneficial. And it actually means that people are going to have more fun or enjoy their dating experience more. Whereas online chatting for extended periods of time actually increases a sense of ideas. realization, it inflates expectations, and it also increases the risk of disappointment because you've
事实的空间。如果他们现在无法表现出来，不，不，不。类似的版本，我的一个朋友实际上有这样一条规则：如果他们在一周内没有见面，我想是一周半，或者在接下来的一周内没有做出具体的见面计划，那么她就会取消匹配。事实证明，许多关于成功使用约会软件的研究都支持这种方法。研究表明，情态转换（modality switching）——基本上就是从线上互动转向线下互动——是非常有益的。这实际上意味着人们会玩得更开心，或者更享受他们的约会体验。然而，长时间的线上聊天实际上会增加理想化（idealization）的感觉，它会抬高期望值，并且由于你
built up a whole fantasy without proof. So setting that timeline to talk within 24 hours, to expect replies within 24 hours, to meet within a week or whatever your timeline is, protects you from creating this parasocial fantasy attachment to someone who, at this stage, is just a string of photos. It's just, like all you know about them is their texting style and a few things that they've sent over message. Another rule that I personally think everyone should abide by is to actually limit your swipes. I know like hinge and Tinder already do this, but like to limit it to five a day, five like, yes, I like them kind of matches. Or to definitely not swipe on anybody you think, hey, I might have to change that about them if I want
在没有证据的情况下建立了一个完整的幻想，从而增加了失望的风险。因此，设定在24小时内对话、期望在24小时内收到回复、在一周内见面的时间表（或你自己的时间表），可以保护你免受对某人的准社会幻想依恋（parasocial fantasy attachment），而在这个阶段，对方只是一串照片。这就像，你对他们的了解仅仅局限于他们的发短信风格以及他们通过信息发送的一些内容。另一条我个人认为每个人都应该遵守的规则是：限制你的右滑次数。我知道像 Hinge 和 Tinder 已经这样做了，但我的意思是将其限制在每天五个，五个“对，我喜欢这种”的匹配。或者绝对不要对任何你觉得“好吧，如果我想和他们长远发展，我可能得改变这一点”的人右滑。或者像“哦，我不太确定，但也许我给他们一个机会吧”这种。不要给机会。如果你不会按照他们现在的样子与他们约会，就不要匹配他们。甚至不要考虑他们的潜力。如果某人在个人简介里写明了——这就是我的意思，这不像我们之前讨论的那样“哦，我不确定是因为我不喜欢他们的衬衫”。我的意思是，如果某人在个人简介里说他们只在寻找短期关系，而你在寻找长期关系，对不起，他们是禁区。如果有人抽烟而你讨厌抽烟，他们是禁区。无论你觉得他们多有吸引力，请记住，这不是一个挑战。这是一个不匹配，这是失望的配方。
be with them long term. Or like, oh, I'm not quite sure, but maybe I'll give them a chance. No chances. If you would not date them as they are now, do not match them. Like, do not even consider it for potential. If someone says on their profile, and this is what I mean, it's not like, oh, I'm not sure because I don't like their shirt like we were talking about before. I mean, like if someone says on their profile, like they're looking for short term and you're looking for long term, I'm sorry, they're off limits. If someone smokes and you hate smoking, they're off limits. no matter how attractive you find them, please know that this is not a challenge. It is a mismatch and it is a recipe for disappointment.
如果你去选择一个你明知无法与你在伴侣需求上匹配的人，在这些情况下，“潜力”就是一个陷阱。这是我们陷入的最大陷阱，因为它在你们甚至还没见面之前就制造了一种伪投资。它还让你陷入这种低级别的稀缺心态，觉得“哦，也许他们有潜力。也许这就是我能找到的最好的了”。约会的全部意义在于寻找契合的伴侣。而不是做他们的生活教练，也不是把某人塑造、捏合成你想要的样子。
If you go for someone who you know isn't going to match what you want in a partner, potential is a trap in these situations. It's the biggest trap we fall into because it creates pseudo-investment before you've even met. It also keeps you in this low-grade scarcity mindset thinking like, oh, maybe they have potential. Maybe this is the best I can do. The whole point of dating is a mutual fit. Not to be their life coach, not to mold somebody into who you want them to be.
所以总结一下第二条小窍门：围绕你如何在约会软件上追求他人或被追求，建立数字和情感边界，并保持一切干净整洁。清理干净你留下的烂摊子。保持无杂乱状态。好吧。在这里再做一次短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，我还有更多的小窍门要送给你们，外加一份我看到在我的某些朋友身上非常成功的线下认识人的指南，所以请继续收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
So to summarize tip number two, create digital and emotional boundaries around how you pursue or are pursued on dating apps and keep it really neat and tidy. Clean up after yourself. Keep it clutter free. Okay. take another short break here, but when we return, I have even more tips for you, plus a guide to how to meet people in person that I've seen be very successful with some of my friends, so stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能以及在我们这个奇奇怪怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，打破主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out,
另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO-Persent，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。任何男人都应该生活在两条黄金规则之下。规则一：永远不要去招惹乡下姑娘。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二：也永远不要去招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的……
on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your...
闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《闺蜜们》的这个新季节里，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们约会过的竟是同一个声名狼藉的世纪骗子。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎，所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他一定会得到应有的惩罚。收听《闺蜜们：相信我，宝贝》。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击（double-tap）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不在乎黑人时。
girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾往昔》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。在每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill
大谈80年代可卡因的节目。申明一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一整天可卡因，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，到了这个时候，这已经是我们第二期讨论可卡因了，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病，所以…… 谢谢你把那句话说完。是的，我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。收听《回顾往昔》，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。欢迎来到我的新播客，
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years. from black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast,
《吃一堑长一智》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的心理治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与众多极其优秀的嘉宾进行的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们正执着于追求某样东西时，
Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这样东西，但我们却依然在追逐，我们甚至不知道什么时候才算“够了”，因为人们总是像看记分牌一样看待生活，生活变成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为地球上的一员做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是因为想做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《吃一堑长一智》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《吃一堑长一智》并立即收听。好的，我们回来了。第三条小窍门，谈谈约会软件的使用准则。我一直坚信你应该主动出击。我不在乎什么规则。我不在乎男人、女人或人们应该扮演什么角色、动力学或诸如此类的东西。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. Okay, we are back. Tip number three, talking about dating app guidelines. I'm always of the belief that you should make the first move. I don't care about rules. I don't care about what roles men or women or people should play or dynamics or whatever it is.
我只觉得规则六：少一点羞怯，多一点直率。现代约会中有一个非常烦人的现象，那就是——没有人想表现得过于热切，但实际上，积极主动并成为第一个采取行动的人，往往能重新赋予你很多自主权，并让你觉得遇到某人的可能性并非遥不可及。我认为约会软件能做的最糟糕的事情，就是让你感到被动。让你觉得自己就像是在苦苦等待某个人从你身边路过并选中你，
I just think rule number six, less coy, more forwardness. There's this really annoying thing that we see a lot in modern dating is, which is that like nobody wants to come off as being too keen, but actually being proactive and being the first one to move, to make that move often restores a lot of agency and makes it feel less impossible that you're going to meet somebody. I think the worst thing that a dating app can do is make you feel passive. Make you feel like you're waiting around for like someone to come across you and to select you
或者等待算法为你推送一个你真正喜欢的对象。这种无力感绝不是我们想要拥有的态度或感觉。当你看到喜欢的人时，为他们打开大门。这里的关键在于，主动出击并不意味着包揽所有的情感劳动。打开大门，看他们是否会顺着你的引导，看他们是否会走进来。但不要开创一种“你将包办一切”的先例。我只是觉得这是一个非常棒的开端。
or for the algorithms to serve you up somebody that you actually like. That powerlessness is not the attitude or the feeling we want to have. When you see someone you like, open the door for them. The key thing here is that making the first move does not mean doing all of the emotional labor. Open the door, see if they follow your lead, see if they walk through it. But don't let it set the precedent that you're going to do everything. I just think it's like a really great first start.
如果他们没有表现出相应的意图，也没有问你问题，或者没有询问你是否想见面以及关于计划的事情，那么我 simplemente（简而言之）觉得他们不值得。如果你是那个主动联系的人，你知道的，你已经……
If they don't match the intention and they don't ask you questions or ask you whether you want to meet up and about plans, then I just don't simply think they're worth it. If you've been the one to reach out, you know, you've made. it as easy as possible for them to pick up on the momentum. And if they don't, the harsh truth is that they're simply just not that into you or just don't have the same capacity for conversation as you do for whatever reason. That's when you apply that other rule that we have unmatched. But rule number three, a quick one, I would say always reach out first.
为他们顺势延续势头创造了尽可能简单的条件。如果他们没有这样做，残酷的真相是，他们要么根本没那么喜欢你，要么无论出于什么原因，他们在对话上的包容度就是不如你高。这就是你该应用我们之前提到的另一条规则：取消匹配。但第三条小窍门，简而言之，我想说：永远要主动联系。
My fourth tip is to make your profile super clear and honest. If you're going to survive the dating apps, give as much information as possible, overcome some of those choice overload barriers that other people are experiencing, that they're experiencing when they're looking at your profile, somebody else's profile, make yourself stand out in a really specific way. I actually had a bit of a formula back in the day for how my profile should be set up. I had this conversation with a dating coach actually on the podcast and she explained how she'd set up the profiles of her single clients on dating apps. So let's assume you're using hinge. The photos she recommended you use were one close up, one full body,
我的第四个建议是让你的个人主页超级清晰且诚实。如果你想在约会软件中生存下来，尽可能多地提供信息，克服其他人正在经历的选择过载障碍，当他们在浏览你的主页或别人的主页时所经历的那种障碍，以一种非常具体的方式脱颖而出。我过去其实有一个关于个人主页应该如何设置的公式。我实际上在播客中与一位约会教练谈过这件事，她解释了她是如何在约会软件上为她的单身客户设置个人主页的。所以，假设你在用 Hinge。她建议你使用的照片是一张特写，一张全身照，
one with your friends, one doing a hobby or like something you love and one conversation starter. So like your dog or like a meme or like a picture of like a broken foot. I don't know. Like this is the hook. This is the picture that somebody can be like, ah, I'm going to grab onto this. This is a conversation starter. and she said it should always be the last picture. So you kind of know like, hey, if someone has responded to this picture, they've swiped all the way through. Like obviously they like what they see. They've made it to the end.
一张和朋友的合照，一张做爱好或喜欢的事情的照片，以及一个开启对话的话题。比如你的宠物、一个表情包，或者一张骨折的照片。我不知道。这就像是吸睛点。这就是可以让别人说：“啊，我要抓住这个”的照片，这是一个开启对话的话题。她说这应该总是最后一张照片。所以你基本上会知道，嘿，如果有人对这张照片做出了回应，他们就已经把照片全部浏览完了。显然他们喜欢他们看到的内容。他们看到了最后。
For questions, for prompts for info, firstly, be like super clear about your intentions. I feel like that goes without saying. Just be as open and honest as you can be. Secondly, choose the most open-ended prompts that you can. the god tear hinge prompt and I believe it always has been this is together we could together we could best hinge prompt
对于问题、提示和个人信息，首先，要超级清楚地表达你的意图。我觉得这不言而喻。尽可能保持开放和诚实。其次，选择你能找到的最开放式的问题提示。神级 Hinge 提示，我相信一直以来都是这个：“在一起我们可以……”“在一起我们可以……”这是最佳的 Hinge 提示
insert your answer something sincere that shows off your true intentions but is also funny one of my friends had like together we could get matching tattoos your choice first like you choose which I love because she's like she's a little wild she's looking for something long term she's like very lovingly the most intense person you'll ever meet she has a tattoo
插入你的回答，一个真诚的答案，既能展现你的真实意图，又不失幽默。我有个朋友的答案是“在一起我们可以去纹情侣纹身，你先选”，我很喜欢，因为她有点疯狂，在寻找长期的关系，她可以说是你会遇到的最热情的人，而且她身上就有纹身
with her now boyfriend. And the responses that she would get were like amazing because it was such a fun conversation started but it also showed intentions. The other good prompts are I geek out on and then add your response and then a little bit about you. And the easiest one is like you should leave a comment if. Open endedness in these situations is rewarded greatly. And on an app or a platform that is designed for first impressions and wants you to make
和她现在的男友一起纹的。她得到的回复简直棒极了，因为这是一个非常有趣的对话切入点，同时也展现了意图。另一个好的提示是“我疯狂迷恋……”然后加上你的回答，再加一点关于你自己的信息。最简单的一个是“如果你……，你应该留个评论”。在这种情况下，开放式的问题会得到丰厚的回报。在一个专为第一印象设计并希望你做出
instantaneous decisions, give people a reason to pause, give people a reason to think a little bit more about you. Now, what I don't mean by saying this is like try and make your profile as appealing to absolutely everybody as possible. I want you to niche down. What you should do instead is make it representative, but also make it very specific. Who are you as a person? How would people describe you. Like, if I could tell, like, if I could maybe crack like your social security code or like your social security questions from your Hinge profile or your Tinder profile, you've done a great job. Think of your profile not as a resume, but as a filter for people applying for you. Even include some of your deal breakers on there if you'd like. Like that leave a comment one,
瞬间决定的软件或平台上，给人们一个停顿的理由，给人们一个多花一点时间了解你的理由。现在，我这么说并不是指尽量让你的个人主页对绝对所有人来说都尽可能地有吸引力。我希望你聚焦于某个细分领域。你真正应该做的是让它具有代表性，同时也非常具体。作为一个人的你是怎样的？别人会怎么形容你。如果我能从你的 Hinge 或 Tinder 个人主页中猜出你的社会保障号或社会保障问题，那你做得太棒了。不要把你的个人主页当成简历，而要把它当作一个为你筛选申请者的过滤器。如果你愿意，甚至可以在上面写上你的一些绝对不能妥协的底线。比如那个留评论的提示，
that's a great one to kind of like see if someone aligns on your values. Like leave a comment if you prefer an alcohol-free first date? Leave a comment if you have no desire to go camping. Leave a comment if your mom is the first person you're going to call after our first date. I love that one. It's a filter, again, them applying to you. Also, and I feel like this goes without saying, use better photos. And if you want to be successful on the dating apps, get your friends to choose your photos for you and then get them to arrange them for you as well. Like, get them to choose every single photo, trust me. This is honestly one of the things I did and it's the tip that I give people the most frequently. I'm not an expert like meeting somebody on a dating
这是一个很好的例子，用来看看某人的价值观是否与你契合。比如：“如果你更喜欢无酒精的第一次约会，请留个评论？”“如果你根本不想去露营，请留个评论？”“如果你妈是我们第一次约会后你打给的第一个人，请留个评论？”我太喜欢这个了。这又是一个过滤器，让他们来申请你。另外，我觉得这不言而喻，用更好的照片。如果你想在约会软件上取得成功，让你的朋友为你挑选照片，然后让他们帮你把照片排好序。真的，让朋友帮你挑选每一张照片，相信我。这真的是我做过的事情之一，也是我给别人最频繁的建议。我不是专家，在约会软件上遇到某人
yet doesn't make me an expert obviously, but I will say my profile was always the most successful when I let my friends put it together and choose my pictures for me. Why? Because I think we often don't perceive ourselves in the most flattering or realistic way. And the photos we choose, I've often found, this reflect countless unconscious reflections on insecurities that we've had for years. I remember one of my friends looking through my hinge once and being like, every single one of these photos, you're only showing the left side of your face. And like you don't have a single body photo. These photos all look the same. And they genuinely were like the exact same photo just in a different font. And I hadn't even realized.
并不意味着我就是专家，但我必须说，每当我让朋友帮我整理个人主页并为我挑选照片时，我的主页总是最成功的。为什么？因为我认为我们往往无法以最讨人喜欢或最现实的方式看待自己。我经常发现，我们自己选择的照片，反映了我们多年来对自身不安全感的无数次无意识投射。我记得我的一个朋友曾经翻看我的 Hinge 主页时说：“你所有的照片里，都只露出了你脸的左侧。而且你一张全身照都没有。这些照片看起来都一模一样。”它们真的就像是同一张照片换了个字体。而我甚至都没有意识到这一点。
This is called, in psychology, unconscious impression management, and it's the ways we try to control how we're perceived without even realizing it, mainly due to our own self-objectification and our own self-monitoring. It's like the same principle behind why people body check or people always gravitate towards certain colors or types of clothes or they don't smile with all their teeth displayed, weird things like that. We all do them, by the way. We all do them.
在心理学中，这被称为无意识印象管理，这是我们在甚至没有意识到自己的情况下试图控制自己被感知方式的方法，主要由于我们的自我客观化和自我监视。这就像人们进行身体检查（body checking）或者总是倾向于某种颜色或类型的衣服、或者拍照时不露出所有牙齿背后遵循的同一种原理，诸如此类的奇怪事情。顺便说一句，我们所有人都会这样做。我们所有人都会这样做。
Dating apps, this is like one of the only times in life where we really get to choose how we're going to be perceived. That sounds like great news, but also at times it can mean projecting someone when not and actually projecting a version of us that is worse than who we actually are because we're trying to hide insecurities that other people don't even notice. Other people love about us. So get your friends to choose your needs. dating app photos, get them to arrange them. Even just give them like a selection of like 30 or 40.
约会软件，这是生活中为数不多的几次我们可以真正选择自己如何被感知的时候。这听起来是个好消息，但有时这也意味着投射出一个不存在的自己，实际上投射出一个比我们真实面貌更糟糕的自己，因为我们在试图隐藏别人甚至根本注意不到的不安全感——而别人其实恰恰喜欢我们的这些特点。所以让你的朋友帮你挑选约会软件的照片，让他们来排版。甚至只需给他们大约 30 到 40 张的选择。
And you just see the difference. It's insane. Okay, tip number five, probably my favorite tip of them all, don't stop meeting people in real life. Dating apps work as a tool for meeting people. They shouldn't be your only solution for romantic interaction. I've noticed online a lot of discourse around how people are now leaving the dating apps in like droves for in-person meetups, for speed dating nights, for dating trivia nights, simply because it's absolutely exhausting to do all that work and never actually meet people. In the UK specifically, in the UK specifically, there was an online report that documented how there have been major declines in the usage of dating apps like Tinder, hinge and bumble compared to the previous year. There was also a lot of,
你会看到区别的。这太疯狂了。好了，第五个建议，可能是我所有人中最喜欢的建议：不要停止在现实生活中结识新的人。约会软件只是结识人的一种工具。它们不应该成为你寻找浪漫互动的唯一解决方案。我注意到网上有很多关于人们现在如何成群结队地离开约会软件去参加线下聚会、快速约会之夜、约会知识问答之夜的讨论，原因很简单，做所有这些工作却从来没有真正见到过人，实在是太累了。具体在英国，具体在英国，有一份网络报告记录了与前一年相比，Tinder、Hinge 和 Bumble 等约会软件的使用量出现了大幅下降。还有很多……
a 2025 study done by researchers in Germany who basically interviewed all these people and found really high signs of dating app fatigue with a lot of participants feeling like they were really worn down by repetitive interactions, by unclear intentions, by how emotional it was to just have all these like these tiny mini connections with people that went nowhere. I honestly think a lot of people are mainly sick of like the transactional nature of it all. It's like all trends or all cultural phenomena. There's always a counterculture. After a while, after things have kind of settled or been the norm for a bit, there's always going to be like this point where people are like, wait, that thing we had before was actually really, really good. Like that thing, the way that we were
德国研究人员在 2025 年做过一项研究，他们基本上采访了所有人，发现约会软件疲劳症的迹象非常高，许多参与者觉得重复的互动、不明确的意图，以及与那些无疾而终的人进行所有这些微小的连接所带来的情绪消耗，让他们精疲力竭。我老实认为，很多人主要是厌倦了这一切的交易性质。就像所有的趋势或所有的文化现象一样。总会有反文化。过了一段时间，当事情已经平息或成为了一段时间的常态之后，总会出现这样一个时刻，人们会说：“等等，我们以前拥有的那个东西其实真的非常好。就像那个东西，在我们这样
operating before this wasn't all that bad. Let's go back there for a little bit. Everything in our lives has turned into something of convenience, efficiency. We can get literally every emotion at our fingertips. We can get humour, validation, anger. Now, supposedly love at our fingertips. And I think people are getting fed up with our dating lives, turning into like another form of Uber rates or another form of gambling. It's the same reason why I think there's been a resurgence, you know, platonically
操作之前的生活并没有那么糟糕。让我们稍微回到过去吧。”我们生活中的一切都变成了便利和效率的代名词。我们可以触手可及地获得字面意义上的每一种情绪。我们可以获得幽默、认可、愤怒。现在，据说爱也是触手可及的。我认为人们开始对我们的约会生活感到厌烦，它变成了另一种形式的 Uber 叫车服务，或者另一种形式的赌博。这就是为什么我认为会有某种复兴的原因，你知道的，柏拉图式的
in like 80s and 90s club activities, like run clubs, book clubs, cinema clubs. outdoor clubs. I'm sure we're going to be doing Tupperware clubs any, like, in the next three months. I'm envisioning it as a trend on TikTok. Honestly, it's a great place to meet people. If you're committed to meeting someone in real life, choose one kind of like mixed gender, social-based activity and be there weekly. Or choose a night of the week where you're like, this is my dating night. I will be going out and I will be meeting people. Trivia nights are another good one.
比如80年代和90年代的俱乐部活动，像跑步俱乐部、读书俱乐部、电影俱乐部、户外俱乐部。我敢肯定，在接下来的三个月里，我们甚至会搞出特百惠（Tupperware）俱乐部。我已经在 TikTok 上把它构想成一个流行趋势了。说实话，这是结识人的好地方。如果你致力于在现实生活中结识某人，选择一种男女混合的、以社交为基础的活动，并且每周都去。或者选择一周中的某一天，告诉自己：“这就是我的约会之夜。我要出门去结识新朋友。”知识问答之夜是另一个好选择。
supper nights. I actually have a really funny story about this. I've obviously just moved to London. I'm in a very happy relationship, but I'm like looking for friends. And so I was like looking up supper clubs and I found this random supper club. It was like geese supper club or something. And I was like, oh, that seems really fun. Geese, you know, they go and they have these dinners and I was like, I love to go out for dinner. So I bought me and my best friend. It was also in a relationship a ticket. And we like get this email and it's like, are you ready to meet your soulmate? And I was like, oh, this is a dating night. So we did end up going.
晚餐俱乐部。我其实有一个关于这方面的非常有趣的趣事。我刚刚搬到伦敦。我处于一段非常幸福的恋关系中，但我当时在找朋友。于是我查了查晚餐俱乐部，找到了这个随机的晚餐俱乐部。好像叫“大雁晚餐俱乐部”还是什么的。当时我想，哦，听起来挺有意思的。大雁，你知道的，它们会去吃这些晚餐，而我也很喜欢出去吃晚餐。所以我给我和我的闺蜜买了一张票——她也是有伴侣的。然后我们收到了一封电子邮件，上面写着：“你准备好遇见你的灵魂伴侣了吗？”当时我就想：“哦，这是一个约会之夜。”所以我们最后还是去了。
But there's so many of those. Check these guys out. I think their next event might have two free seats because unfortunately we can't make it. But another way to do this, Supple Club's trivia, I've already said those, but start giving people your number. Do it. I'm serious. Take it as rejection therapy. If they reject you, you win because you realize it's not a big deal and you'll continue to thrive and be brave.
但这种活动真的很多。去看看这些人吧。我想他们的下一场活动可能会有两个免费名额，因为不幸的是我们去不了。但做这件事的另一种方法，晚餐俱乐部、知识问答，我刚才已经说过了，开始把你的电话号码给别人。去做吧。我是认真的。把它当作拒绝疗法。如果他们拒绝了你，你赢了，因为你意识到这没什么大不了的，你将继续蓬勃发展，勇敢面对。
if, you know, they do say yes, great, you've got a date. I was at the pub the other night and someone gave this girl his number. And me and my friend were watching this interaction and we were like, his friends, it was kind of this weird sitting where we could see what was happening, but she couldn't see what was happening behind her. And his friends were like hyping him up. Like they were like pushing him to do it and then she was blushing and it was just really, he was blushing. And that was just like romance right there. Get your number, printed on some business cards, give them out, you have nothing to lose. Also ask your friends to set you up, especially your friends with boyfriends or girlfriends or partners.
如果他们说“好”，太棒了，你有个约会了。我前几天在酒吧，有人把自己的电话号码给了一个女孩。我和朋友看着这个互动，我们就像是他的朋友一样——当时那是个奇怪的坐位，我们可以看到发生了什么，而她看不到她背后发生的事。他的朋友们在为他起哄。他们就像是在推着他去行动，然后她脸红了，这也真的很……他脸红了。这就好比浪漫就在眼前。把你的电话号码印在一些名片上，发出去，你没有什么可失去的。另外，让你的朋友为你牵线搭桥，尤其是那些有男友、女友或伴侣的朋友。
Because guess what? Guess what those partners have? They have single friends of their own. And let's be real. Everyone has the dream of dating best friends or at least close friends. They will be like, they will be on it like Veggie Mine on Toast. As soon as my single girlfriends are like, I want to meet somebody, Tom's friends are getting interrogated. I'm going through his recent texts to remind myself who our eligible bachelors are.
因为你猜怎么着？你猜那些伴侣有什么？他们有他们自己的单身朋友。说实话。每个人都有和最好的朋友或者至少是亲密的朋友约会的梦想。他们会对此上心的，就像对 Vegemite 吐司一样热切。一旦我的单身闺蜜说“我想认识个人”，汤姆的朋友们就要接受盘问了。我正在翻看他最近的短信，提醒自己我们有哪些合格的单身汉。
A date is being planned. Mark my words. I've also seen success with like speed dating meetups as well. Or there is this one club in London that I love. The woman who runs it is so cool. And it's called Scouting for Sexies where they go around London pubs and like, hang out with the girls but also chat up guys I think are cute for the fun of it for the vibes and like with their friends this is the energy we're bringing these are the spaces we want to be in when dating apps are exhausting I think meeting people in person just gets rid of that
一场约会正在筹划中。记住我的话。我也看到过快速约会聚会取得成功。或者伦敦有这样一个我特别喜欢的俱乐部。运营它的那个女生太酷了。它叫“Scouting for Sexies”（寻帅之旅），她们会在伦敦的酒吧里四处转转，和女生们一起玩，同时也会为了好玩、为了氛围去搭讪她们觉得可爱的男生，和朋友们一起。这就是我们带来的能量，这就是我们想要身处的空间。当约会软件让人精疲力竭时，我认为在现实中结识人正好可以摆脱那一层
first layer of bullshit if I'm being honest like it's one less layer of pretense you get like a much richer sense of who someone is in person you know whether there's that warmth, that humor, just seeing what their energy is like. And you've also already cleared like the first three barriers that dating apps usually put up as well. You know, having to match, having to talk, having to make plans. You skip all that. You're already on stage four. And just that shared context as well can make closeness feel much more natural, much quicker
虚伪的第一层皮，老实说，这就是少了一层伪装。你在现实中能对一个人有更丰富的感知，你知道那里是否有那种温暖、那种幽默，只要看看他们的能量是怎样的。而且你还已经清除了约会软件通常设置的前三道障碍。你知道的，必须配对、必须聊天、必须制定计划。你跳过了所有这些。你已经直接进入第四阶段了。而且那种共同的背景也能让亲密感感觉更加自然、更加迅速，
because there's less pressure to perform. If you're serious about surviving the dating apps, I think my message here, is don't become dependent on them. Don't let their dominance limit how you think people meet and fall in love because there are still offline love stories. I promise you. Yours could very easily be the next one. I'm sensing it. Okay, we're going to take one more short break, but when we return, I have two final tips for you.
因为表演的压力更小了。如果你是认真的想在约会软件中生存下来，我想我在这里要传达的信息是，不要对它们产生依赖。不要让它们的主导地位限制你对人们如何相遇和坠入爱河的看法，因为线下依然有爱情故事。我向你保证。你的故事非常轻松地就会成为下一个。我感觉得到。好了，我们要再进行一次短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，我还有最后两个建议给你。
So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator. available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out
所以请继续收听。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇特的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们对之恐慌的许多问题
that in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man.
世界上发生的事情都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》，即 T-W-O-Percent。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《闺蜜》中……哦天哪，这就是同一个人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。我说：“哦，见鬼，绝不。”我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。他必须受到应有的惩罚。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know.
乔治·布什跟小金姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是 Sam J。还有我 Alex English。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·hill，大谈80年代的可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一聊可卡因，但只是为了让你们都知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。然后你把那句话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan, Ryan, Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹、瑞恩、瑞恩……有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了一场场胜负的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同信任层级。我希望你纯粹是因为想成为一个好人而去这样做。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. This is probably my least practical tip
和我——基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、父职、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。这可能是我最不实用的一条建议了，
of all, but my most important. Tip number six, take absolutely nothing personally. Nothing. Commit to being as stoic as possible about the losses. Dating apps generate, again, an extraordinary amount of ambiguous social feedback. It might be a match who never replies and you assume that that says something about you or someone who's really enthusiastic and then you go on one date, you never hear from them again, even though you thought it went really well. And this ambiguity is naturally very confusing
但在我所有的建议中是最重要的。第六条建议，绝对不要把任何事情当作针对你个人。任何事。下定决心，对所有的损失保持尽可能坦然的态度。约会软件会再次产生大量的模糊社交反馈。可能是一个从不回复你的配对，而你以为这说明了你自身的问题，或者是一个原本非常热情的人，然后你们进行了一次约会，就再也没有听到他们的消息，尽管你觉得进展非常顺利。这种模糊性自然是非常令人困惑的，
for our minds. That kind of doesn't know where to store that information. It doesn't know what that situation meant. So we fill in the blanks with the most egocentric answers possible. The one, the answer that puts our actions and our words at the center. I was boring. I said something wrong. I wasn't cool enough. It's very egotistical, like I said. And there's no wonder, you know, we've spoken about this on the podcast before, but we know from research that social rejection literally hurts us physically. But it will hurt you less when you first. When you first focus on the reasons that have nothing to do with you at all. And you actually stop putting yourself at the center here.
对我们的头脑来说。它不知道该把这些信息储存在哪里。它不知道那种情况意味着什么。所以我们用尽可能以自我为中心的答案来填补空白。那个把我们的行动和言语置于中心的答案。我很无聊。我说错话了。我不够酷。正如我所说，这是非常以自我为中心的。难怪——我们以前在播客中讨论过这个——我们从研究中得知，社会拒绝在字面意义上会让我们感到身体上的疼痛。但当你首先关注那些与你完全无关的原因时，它给你的伤害就会减少。当你真正停止把自己放在核心位置时。
If you did get a reply, but then communication drops off, you know what? Yeah, they could be dating somebody else. They could also be overwhelmed. They could be dealing with personal stuff. They could realize they're not over their ex. They maybe are just thoughtless. Maybe they just wanted a bit of validation. Who cares?
如果你确实得到了回复，但随后的交流减少了，你知道吗？是的，他们可能在和别人约会。他们也可能不堪重负。他们可能在处理个人的事情。他们可能意识到自己还没有放下前任。他们也许只是考虑不周。也许他们只是想要一点肯定。谁在乎呢？
Who cares? There are so many explanations that have nothing to do with you. Learn to ignore everything but the positive experiences. However, you want to sell it to yourself. On the apps, the barrier to matching with somebody is so tiny. You can literally do it in a second. So you have to remember, like, the perceived cost of just disappearing is also really small. People don't think about it.
谁在乎呢？有那么多解释与你毫无关系。学会忽略除了积极体验之外的一切。无论你想怎么自我安慰。在软件上，与某人配对的门槛太低了。你字面意义上一秒钟就能做到。所以你必须记住，仅仅是消失这种行为的感知成本也很低。人们不会去考虑这些。
People get very callous and they swipe when they're bored, when they're lonely, when, you know, they have nothing to do. I can admit I even did that. Everyone does it. Dating apps make you a kind of a mean person and a careless person. Don't take a match as a promise. It's not a sign of intention. A message is a sign of intention.
人们变得非常冷酷，当他们无聊时、孤独时、无所事事时，就会去右滑。我承认我甚至也做过这种事。每个人都这么做。约会软件让你变成了一个有点刻薄的人和一个粗心的人。不要把一次配对当成承诺。它不是意图的信号。一条消息才是意图的信号。
A match is nothing. It's just a quick signal that they find you attractive. They like your vibe. But the sheer volume of people on the apps that we're exposed to, means that, again, our brains aren't actually equipped to deal with all that information. And that is why when people don't always follow through, it's not reflective of anything about you. It's reflective of the design of the app, of how they are made to make money, like we've spoken about. One of my friends actually has this beautiful way of seeing it every time a couple finds each other on an app.
配对什么都不是。它只是一个快速的信号，表明他们觉得你有吸引力。他们喜欢你的氛围。但我们在软件上接触到的人数之多，意味着我们的头脑再次没有真正配备好去处理所有这些信息。这就是为什么当人们并不总是兑现承诺时，这并不能反映你身上的任何问题。它反映的是软件的设计，反映了它们是如何为了赚钱而被制造出来的，正如我们所讨论的那样。我的一个朋友实际上有一种美妙的看法，每当有一对情侣在软件上找到彼此，
there are five, ten, maybe 15 people they were talking to whose story ends there who was left disappointed but those stories have to end for that other story to work out and when you finally find somebody that it works out with there will be stories that prematurely end for others as well in order for yours to begin.
总会有五个、十个、甚至十五个他们曾经聊过的人，他们的故事到此为止，留下了失望。但这些故事必须结束，另一个故事才能顺利发展。而当你最终找到一个能与你修成正果的人时，也会有其他人的故事提前结束，为了你的故事而开始。
It's all in exchange. You're paying your dues, you're ticking off your numbers you're paying your tax however you want to see it to remain neutral the neutrality is important. I know that all sounds a little bit brutal, but stoicism, acceptance of that nature is freedom and anything, really. That brings me to our last tip.
这一切都是一种交换。你在付出代价，你在勾掉你的数字，你在交你的税，无论你想怎么看，都要保持中立。这种中立很重要。我知道这听起来有点残酷，但斯多葛主义、对这种性质的接纳，其实就是任何事情的自由。这就引出了我们的最后一个建议。
Tip number seven, if you want to survive the dating apps, periodically you need to delete the dating apps, especially the moment they start to feel like a chore. Or you feel like it's been weeks since you wanted to go on a date with anyone. That is a great sign. You are at the tail end of a burnout.
第七条建议，如果你想在约会软件中生存下来，你需要定期删除约会软件，尤其是当它们开始感觉像是一件苦差事的时候。或者你觉得已经好几个星期不想和任何人约会了。这是一个好兆头。你正处于精疲力竭的尾声。
I think there is, and I know there is, a pressure to be like dating at 100% if you say you're dating. And showing up day after day on the apps out of fear that you're going to miss the love of your life and never have an opportunity to match with them again. Do you know how many times I match with the same people multiple times? Like, because I deleted and came back. You don't have to become permanently. disenfranchised with dating because you keep thinking you need to push through the burnout that the apps bring. You want to be able to have a healthy relationship with this. I think deleting when you feel
我认为并且我知道存在这样一种压力，即如果你说你在约会，就必须保持 100% 的投入。日复一日地出现在软件上，是出于害怕错过你一生挚爱、再也没有机会与他们再次配对的恐惧。你知道我跟同一群人多次配对过多少次吗？就像，因为我删了又重新下载。你不需要因为你一直认为你需要咬牙挺过软件带来的精疲力竭，而对约会彻底绝望。你希望能够与这种状态保持健康的联系。我认为当你觉得
like you and the apps aren't clicking, taking two to three months off reduces the pessimism that you can have around all dating. But additionally, I think it will also reduce the chances of you settling for less just so that you can stop dating, just so that you can feel less frustrated. And it also stops you from getting too emotionally invested in people who don't respond or who don't get back to you because the sense of urgency is less intense. I will say when I met my partner Tom on Hinge, I had done a six-month dating app detox. And I'm not saying this is going to happen to you, but I re-downloaded the app and he was the first person I matched with. And that's the thing.
你和软件之间擦不出火花时，删除它，休息两到三个月，可以减少你对所有约会的悲观情绪。但此外，我认为它还能减少你为了停止约会、为了减少挫败感而将就的几率。它还能阻止你对那些不回复你或不理睬你的投入过多情感，因为紧迫感没有那么强烈了。我必须说，当我遇到我的伴侣汤姆时，是在 Hinge 上，我当时已经进行了长达六个月的约会软件排毒。我不是说这一定会在你身上发生，但我重新下载了软件，他就是我配对的第一个人。这就是关键所在。
When you are feeling more high energy, you can come back and actually start having fun with it again. Like, I felt like there was nothing left for me and then it was like, oh, this great person had rejoined whilst I was gone. Then you can really organize loads of dates. You get to talk to people you're actually interested in. You just get to like enjoy it. One of my favorite creators called Rach, I think her name's like Rache Rat or something.
当你感觉能量更高时，你可以回来，重新开始从中获得乐趣。比如，我觉得已经没什么好期待的了，然后就像是，哦，在我离开的时候，这个棒极了的人又加入了。然后你真的可以组织大量的约会。你可以和那些你真正感兴趣的人交谈。你就能真正享受它。我最喜欢的一个创作者叫 Rach，我想她的名字叫 Rache Rat 之类的，
it's, I think it's Rache Rat, but she posts her dating diaries on TikTok and something she says is that the early stages of dating is only meant to be two things, sexy and fun. Sexy and fun. And if they're not, what is the point? So if you feel like your options are dwindling, come back two, three, four months, six months. Also, there's going to, like, the reserves are going to be refreshed. Like, it's going to be a whole new set of people. People break up all the time.
我想是 Rache Rat，她在 TikTok 上发布她的约会日记，她说的一件事是，约会的早期阶段应该只有两件事：性感和有趣。性感和有趣。如果不是这样，那还有什么意义？所以如果你觉得你的选择在减少，那就回来两、三个月、四个月、六个月。而且，资源将会得到补充。比如，将会有一批全新的人。人们一直在分手，
people suddenly heal from breakups and come back on the apps all the time, back on the market. The last thing dating apps should make you feel is like your options are limited or scarce because that is what they want you to feel and they want to trap you into spending money and maybe even settling. So remember, fun and sexy is your objective. Dating burnout is so real and it's not sexy and it's not fun. So take a step back until you feel like you want to give it another try. there is no rush. I know, especially as we kind of get into like a late 20s and 30s and even older,
人们突然从分手中恢复过来，并一直不断地回到软件上，重返市场。约会软件最不应该让你感觉到的，就是你的选择是有限的或稀缺的，因为这正是他们希望你感受到的，他们想把你套牢在花钱甚至将津上。所以请记住，有趣和性感才是你的目标。约会倦怠是如此真实，它既不性感也不有趣。所以退后一步，直到你觉得你想再试一次。不用着急。我知道，尤其是当我们进入二十多岁后期、三十多岁甚至更大年龄时，
like there's such an urgency to find somebody before opportunities and options and doors close. This is going to maybe be advice you don't want to hear, but I think urgency and panic is the worst thing you can do because it's always going to mean that you make a poorer decision. going steadier, slower, having rules for yourself, having practices, rituals around dating, like treating dating apps like the game and the business model they are, is going to make you so much more effective in the long run. And I think the mindset that is united every single person who I've seen been successful in a dating app is just,
那种必须在机会、选择和门关闭之前找到某人的紧迫感是如此强烈。这可能是你不想听的建议，但我认为紧迫感和恐慌是你最糟糕的做法，因为这意味着你总是会做出更糟糕的决定。保持平稳、放慢节奏，为自己设定规则、制定关于约会的准则和仪式——就像把约会软件当作它们本来就是的游戏和商业模式一样对待——从长远来看会让你高效得多。而且我认为，我在所有在约会软件上取得成功的人身上都看到过的一种共同的心态就是：
I am here to not take this very seriously. and I'm here with very low, if not, no expectations. And in that way, I'm actually able to enjoy this. So I hope this advice has been helpful. Thank you so much for listening. Thank you, as always, to our researcher, Libby Colbert for her contributions to this episode. Our question for the day, if you have made it this far, thank you for listening. Thanks for being a loyal listener.
我来这里不是为了把这看得很严肃。我带着非常低的期望值，甚至没有期望来到这里。通过这种方式，我实际上能够享受这个过程。所以我希望这些建议对你们有所帮助。非常感谢你们的收听。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特对本集节目的贡献。我们今天的每日问题，如果你能听到这里，谢谢你的收听。谢谢你成为一个忠实的听众。
What's your dream date? Leave a comment down below. Dream date, you get to choose four activities. three activities, whatever, what would it be? I think my dream date, I was thinking about this the other day, dream date would be, go to the beach, then go home, like, separately, have a shower, meet again, a little bit sun-kissed for like an early dinner, like a sunset dinner, have a few wires, have a few dinner, have a bit to eat and then like have a walk home and it's summertime.
你梦想中的约会是什么样的？在下方留个评论吧。梦想中的约会，你可以选择四个活动。三个活动，随便什么，会是什么样的？我想我梦想中的约会，我前几天还在想这个，梦想中的约会是，去海滩，然后回家，分开走，洗个澡，再次碰面，带着一点阳光亲吻的肤色去吃一顿早晚餐，就像日落晚餐那样，喝几杯酒，吃点晚饭，吃一点东西，然后散步走回家，而且正是夏天。
And it's beautiful and then like a little kiss before, before they leave. That's my dream date. leave yours below and make sure you're following us on Instagram. Also, as I mentioned at the beginning of this episode, the psychology of your 20s is now on Netflix. So if you are based in the US, please feel free to listen to watch over there. I'd love to see you there.
天气晴好，然后在他们离开之前，有一个小小的吻。这就是我梦想中的约会。在下方留下你的梦想约会，并确保你在 Instagram 上关注了我们。另外，正如我在本集节目开始时提到的那样，《你的二十岁心理学》现在已经在 Netflix 上线了。所以如果你在美国，请随时去那里收听观看。我很希望在那里见到你。
It's like a crazy thing for the podcast. So yeah, any support on that would be very much appreciated. Also, I just think the quality is really cool. It just brings a whole new personal layer to the podcast. broadcast that I really enjoy, so I'd love to see you over there. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We'll talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations
这对于这个播客来说是一件很疯狂的事情。所以，是的，对这件事的任何支持都将不胜感激。另外，我也觉得这个画质真的很酷。它为播客带来了一个全新的个人层面，我真的很喜欢，所以我很想在那里见到你。但直到下一次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再次交谈。嘿，各位最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，
that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. And you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
这些对话在其他地方真的不太安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇特的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难。你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。也就是 TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己动手。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他将得到他应得的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J.
收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是 Sam J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
还有我 Alex English。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证是由真人制作的。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。